bonsoir à tous merci de votre attention
bagdad aux mains des américains après
trois semaines de guerre édition
spéciale du journal avec tout de suite
ces quelques images qui résume
l'essentiel
d'abord la chute de saddam hussein le
despote reste introuvable mais sa statue
a été déboulonnée il ya un peu plus de
trois heures sur la place centrale de
bagdad
images des irakiens en liesse on a
observé scènes de joie ce matin dans les
rues désertées par les forces du régime
même s'il faut le noter la plupart des
habitants sont restés chez eux
images des chars américains au coeur de
la capitale
installé sur les principales avenues la
ville est-elle entièrement sous contrôle
non a répondu l'état major tout à
l'heure plusieurs quartiers ne sont pas
sécurisées enfin images d'une situation
fragile et d'un risque de chaos
le pillage systématique dans les
magasins et les bâtiments officiels
la guerre n'est donc pas finie la mais
la bataille de bagdad est terminé ou
presque on commence avec ses premières
scènes qui ont marqué la débâcle du
régime c'était en fin de matinée les
chars américains progressent dans les
quartiers populaires pratiquement sans
résistance et la population descend dans
les rues
des scènes de liesse limité mais bien
réel
hervé ghesquière il n'ya de dieu que
allah et sa dame est l'ennemi d'allah un
mélange de ferveur religieuse de joie et
de soulagement dans le quartier de
saddam city
ici la majorité chiite déshérité à et et
tyrannisé humilier pendant toute la
période de la dictature du parti baas
plus de 45 ans aujourd'hui sous la
bannière noire chi c'est un jour de
délivrance
les jeunes en profitent pour hurler
oui au schisme bientôt pouvoir
à quelques kilomètres près du centre de
bagdad
les blindés américains acclame
après trois semaines de conflit voilà
des images que washington
n'attendez plus mais quelques irakiens
restent méfiants drapeau blanc à la main
parfois même les bras en l'air tous
paraissent être des civils
d'autres des combattants ont abandonné
toute lutte il s'éloigne presque
tranquillement
la guerre semble finie même si des
escarmouches reste possible ici ou là
dans un autre quartier de bagdad cette
scène inimaginable
il y encore quelques heures un jeune
garçon s'attaque à une statue de saddam
hussein puis d'autres suivent le
défoulement devant des soldats
américains
interloqué un marines demande de reculer
même s'il comprend ce drôle de jeu puis
un baghdadi revient à la charge pour
insulter le raïs mais dans la capitale
irakienne
tous n'ont pas tourné la page de la
guerre il y a encore et toujours un
sentiment de révolte contre les
américains cet homme brandit des habits
d'enfants ensanglanté puis emmène les
journalistes vers la famille endeuillée
qu'a fait cet enfant pour mériter la
mort hurle les parents anéantis
pour eux le jour de la chute de saddam
restera un jour de désespoir
un peu plus tard c'est au tour de la
plus grande des statuts de saddam
hussein que se sont rassemblés les
habitants de bagdad
la suite raconté par jérôme soûlard
c'était le plus grand le plus haut le
plus lourd symbole du pouvoir de saddam
hussein sur l'irak une statue géante du
reich sur laquelle la foule va se
déchaîner
on hurle sa joie ou sa colère et
pourtant tout n'a pas été si simple pour
offrir aux caméras du monde entier
cette image de libération deux heures
plus tôt sans adversaire ni combat les
chars américains prennent position sur
la place du paradis elle farde house le
signal de la fin d'une époque pour une
centaine de jeunes irakiens qui attaqua
la masse est gigantesque statue
le geste est dérisoire mais qu'importe
ils seront nombreux à vouloir le répéter
un blindé américain vient donc à leur
secours
une cordée même accroché au cou de
saddam le dictateur pendant quelques
secondes à marine sauve a même dressé le
drapeau américain sur le visage du rail
ce geste formellement interdit par son
état-major erreur de communication vite
rectifié on accroche donc un drapeau
irakien
l'un des plus orgueilleux symbole du
pouvoir peut désormais céder
le visage de saddam hussein celui que
tout irakien devait adulé en public mais
plus qu'un trophée qui ne fait plus peur
à personne
mais dans cette ville en ébullition on a
aussi assisté à des scènes de chaos on
vole tous des fauteuils des lavabos tout
semble bon à prendre commenté olivier
gasnier
un béret un baiser dit cet homme il est
content il a de quoi
aujourd'hui bagdad n'est plus qu'un
grand supermarché
gratuit première cible des pillages les
bâtiments publics
ici nous sommes au ministère de
l'irrigation et ironie de l'histoire les
fleurs sont en plastique
qu'importe elles seront embarqués aussi
bouchegouf dit ce garçon bush va te
faire voir et pour l'os à l'heure du
grand pillage les convictions politiques
sont encore secondaire un gamin mettra
tout le monde d'accord c'est allah qui
est grand on a même les chaises
un peu plus loin le quartier général du
fils aîné de saddam la lane du régime
est nettement plus visible
venez venez vous exprimer librement qui
s'étonne venaient les opprimés cet homme
nous a tué il a tué notre jeunesse il a
tué les meilleurs d'entre nous ce
criminel ce mécréant à quelques mètres
de là le pillage des ors du pouvoir se
poursuit
tout y passe y compris le plus futile
dans cette atmosphère de fin de règne
les chars américains ne sont même plus
un objet de curiosité leur unique
mission est d'ailleurs d'avancé pas
d'arrêter les pillages
et c'est comme ça dans toute la ville à
chacun son ministère ici nous sommes
dans celui de l'agriculture ou ce qu'il
en reste
en quelques minutes il sera totalement
vidée image surréaliste
celle ci résume peut-être aujourd'hui à
elle seule la chute de bagdad
les commentaires d'un commandant
américain c'est une honte mais nous ne
sommes pas ici pour faire la police mais
pour des opérations militaires il faut
dire que des groupes de tireurs isolés
sont restés actifs et le reste encore ce
soir dans certains quartiers voici la
journée tel que l'ont vécu nos envoyés
spéciaux un reportage d'une intensité
particulière dans une ville en train de
basculer
bertrand cocq emmanuel bec n'avais pas
pleuré et grégoire deniau de l' agence
capa touché à mort un camion à chef de
brûler des combattants sans fui à
travers champs
ils abandonnent leurs positions il est
10 heures du matin les américains ont
routes ouvertes jusqu'au coeur de la
capitale s'est terminée confirme un
gamin qui vient de jeter son arme tous
les fedayin son parti et pour la
première fois depuis trente ans les
irakiens n'ont plus peur du régime et de
son chef dans sa dame city le grand
quartier chiite
les habitants pillent d'une caserne du
parti baas
le précédent régime était mauvais le
suivant le sera aussi bien sucré
bédouins nous les pauvres
nous sommes toujours perdants les motos
l'avenir c'est dieu qui l'écrit il se
rappelle dans le centre ville les
derniers kamikazes tente un baroud
d'honneur à deux pas du ministère de
l'information
ils montent vers un improbable assaut en
hurlant le nom de dieu que la famille du
prophète soit avec nous crie ces jeunes
fedayin dont la majorité ne sont même
pas irakien dans cet entre-deux
chaotique des pillards vite quelques
boutiques abandonné
les combattants retournent leurs armes
contre eux bagdad sera toujours
vainqueur clame l'homme ok fier qu'un
civil implore de cesser le combat
tu n'as que ton fusil lui dit il et en
face il y as a depuis le matin ils sont
à bagdad comme chez eux ici sur la rive
orientale du tigre dans un quartier
résidentiel
vous croyez que c'est fini j'espère
envie de rentrer à la maison
oui un autre ji yai a récupéré un fusil
d'assaut kalachnikov
ils l'ont abandonné c'est un super la
suite c'est comme au cinéma
les gi's s'empare sans opposition d'un
complexe de la garde républicaine
l'endroit est désert mais dans toutes
les pièces est toujours accroché le
portrait de celui que les irakiens
acclament est encore il ya deux jours
les gi's ont aperçu quelques civils dans
la maison d'en face
mais la population est accueillante
hanna rosin à notre chauffeur a pris la
tangente
meehan irakiens se propose de nous
ramener à l'hôtel fini salam hussein des
maisons les gens sortent
nous offrons des bières la première fois
cela au moins se sentent libérés
ce n'est pas le cas de tout le monde
il reste quelques poches de résistance
devant l'impôt vide de trois hommes sans
chef vident leurs derniers charger sur
un ennemi invisible
ceci rien nous montre pourquoi il se bat
le coran
mais plus rien n'arrête désormais la
progression des blindés américains dans
l'est de la capitale
partout des vivats des drapeaux blancs
les sifflets d'encouragement je suis
heureux heureux ce que je ressens c'est
le bonheur de la liberté de nos
relations avec eux plutôt bonne je crois
qu'il nous aime bien
je sais pas combien de temps va rester
dans ce pays on verra il est 4 heures de
l'après midi lorsque les plaint des
rallyes l'hôtel palestine celui des
journalistes
celui que ces mêmes américains ont
bombardé hier par erreur une pacifiste
interpelle un chef de char sur sa
tourelle toute élégance à l'audience qui
tu étais où le 11 septembre lui répond
le soldat je t'emmerde tueur d'enfant
allez voir à l'hôpital ce que vous avez
fait hurle encore la pacifiste et la
plupart des boys s'en moquer éperdument
et le jeune tankiste est tout à son
bonheur il a l'air d'un bébé il a 20 ans
comme entre hostile les irakiens sympa
accueillants ils sont contents qu'on
soit là c'est géant
je leur ai pas décrire ce que je ressens
c'est fort hic
devant les quelques officiels irakiens
qui n'ont pas pris la poudre
d'escampette
les américains pénètre alors dans
l'hôtel le lieutenant-colonel mccoy du
corps des marines grimpe directement
dans le bureau du directeur et prend
possession des lieux et voilà on est
capable et saddam hussein orizet
j'espère qu'il est mort à défaut de
pouvoir produire l'original mon avis les
sapeurs du colonel mccoy des sites alors
de se payer la statue du raïs des faits
la première d'une longue série a
dégringolé de son piédestal
voilà pour ce reportage de bertrand cocq
emmanuel bec et grégoire deniau en
direct de bagdad
nous retrouvons un autre de nos envoyés
spéciaux gérard griesbeck bonsoir gerra
première chose donc si on a bien compris
ces images dans l'hôtel où résident les
journalistes vous n'avez plus autour de
vous
ces guides entre guillemets chargé de
vous encadrez non effectivement ils se
sont envolés il s'était déjà envolé hier
après-midi en est le chef de de presse
monsieur
oudaï elle taille qu'on avait d'ailleurs
interviewé deux fois ici sur notre
antenne
j'avais rendez vous avec lui hier à 17
heures on m'a dit va arriver un petit
peu en retard je l'attends toujours il
est vraiment très très en retard et ce
matin surprise au moment où nous
partions portage et bien ils n'avaient
plus le chauffeur il n'y avait plus de
traducteur il n'y avait plus de guide
tous ces gens qui nous ont recadré
pendant des semaines voire des mois pour
nous donner la bonne parole ce sont
effectivement envolée on avait déjà
senti ce climat de délitement du régime
gérard on peut dire ce soir que c'est la
fin du régime de saddam hussein oui oui
on peut le dire évidemment là la
bataille n'est pas totalement gagné à
bagdad mais on peut dire
qu'effectivement ce régime est tombé la
symbolique c'est l'arrivée vous l'avez
vu dans le reportage de bertrand cocq
c'est l'arrivée donc de ces chars
américains à la rencontre de l'hôtel
palestine et des journalistes qui
étaient là pour filmer leur arrivée
triomphale dans la ville
mais c'est vrai que c'est la fin de ce
régime qui visiblement tombe sans
vraiment une grosse résistance ce soir
gérard le sentiment de la population on
a vu des scènes de liesse mais on ne
peut pas dire que tout le monde soit
descendue dans la rue pour fêter les
soldats américains
non c'est vrai que les scènes dolia sont
les a surtout vu dans le nord de bagdad
le quartier de salam city qui est un
énorme quartier c'est quasiment une
ville dans la ville
ce composé essentiellement de gens de
religions musulmane chiite
et ces gens qui sont environ un million
donc c'est quand même un énorme quartier
ces gens beaucoup souffert de saddam
hussein dont on savait que sans doute si
des irakiens deviez devait bien
accueillir les libérateurs entre
guillemets américain va ce serait bien
ces gens là ce sont donc ces gens là
pour voir sur les images on se promenant
pas très loin d'ici dans d'autres
quartiers
on voit bien que les gens sont soulagés
mais de là à être très content c'est une
autre paire de manches
effectivement je pense que peu de gens
regretteront ce régime terrible saddam
hussein mais pour autant ce qui domine
ce soir c'est quand même une inquiétude
sur l'avenir et les gens sont plus
préoccupés par des problèmes
d'alimentation
dead humanitaire et sanitaire parce
qu'il sort quand même de 10 ans
d'embargo
plutôt que de problèmes politiques merci
gérard on y reviendra effectivement un
peu plus tard pour mieux mesurer en tout
cas ce sentiment dans la ville une autre
de nos équipes à bagdad est allé ce
matin à la rencontre des chars qui
arrivait en centre ville à la rencontre
de soldats américains incrédule
d'ailleurs atmosphère de fin de règne
c'est un reportage de briller de l'air
sylvain doba et vincent lejeune
pour eux la bataille de bagdad est
terminée après une nuit de combats
sporadiques 200 hommes de la 1ère
division de marines ont pris possession
de la rive orientale du tigre de
bassorah ils ont remonté la route numéro
6 à l'est du pays
on devine aux véhicules calcinés que la
résistance irakienne a été inutile
dans les débris encore fumants des
cadavres en civil des restes de
kalachnikov
rien d'autre les marines n'ont pas
lésiné même pour eux le spectacle est
difficilement supportable
l'unité lima 37 s'offre une pause
l'ambiance est détendue mais vigilante
l'armée irakienne est en déroute les
attentats suicides restent à craindre
ce livre raconte qu'il s'attendait à
davantage de résistance qu'ils se
demandent si les combattants irakiens
sont courageux ou stupide d'avoir osé se
bat
face à eux les bacs des dinos pose
aucune résistance
les drapeaux blancs de fortune font leur
apparition bras levés ils apprennent
d'un coup ce que l'occupation veut dire
avant cet irakien nous dit que rien
n'est terminé hallyday son coeur ni dans
son âme
les américains dit il sur la honte de
l'humanité ils disent qu'ils sont venus
aider l'irak alors qu'ils ne sont que
les menteurs et des [ __ ] d'alpha
cause avant 100 m par m les marines se
valent rapidement les deux derniers
kilomètres
au moindre doute il tire la population
insiste immobile à la chute de sa
capitale quelques vives à de maigres
applaudissements
difficile de savoir ce qu'ils ressentent
vraiment nous dit qu'il souhaiterait
pouvoir chasser les tanks de sa vie et
innovantes on lui rappelle qu'il n'y a
juste d'applaudir les américains et la
fouille un peu gêné un autre s'interpose
alors disant que l'important est d'avoir
à manger de l'électricité ailleurs dans
la ville l'atmosphère est délétère et
les rues désertées sont la proie des
profiteurs de guerre tout est bon à
prendre au plus vite
à bagdad ce soir c'est la débâcle
organisé en vacance de pouvoir les
irakiens sont livrés à eux mêmes alors
que les américains n'ont pas encore fini
de sécuriser leur position
voilà l un de ces américains est avec
nous maintenant en direct de bagdad le
capitaine brian mingan bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous avant de parler de ce
sentiment d baghdadi votre sentiment à
vous capitaine d'abord est ce que vous
pensiez que ce serait aussi facile de
prendre bagdad
et qu'avez vous ressenti ce matin dans
ces heures d'arrivée au centre ville que
je ne dirais pas que ce serait facile de
prendre bagdad
je pense qu'il ya suffisamment de gens
qui ne sont pas contents de nous voir
arriver
donc je pense que j'aurai tort de dire
que nous avons pris ben adda nous avons
sécurisé des zones à bagdad
mais il reste des choses à faire
avez vous eu peur pendant ces heures
d'offensive
pas vraiment je suis confiant dans les
marines qui nous entoure ce n'est pas
notre première bataille
nous avons appris à me battre contre les
irakiens qui ont choisi de se battre
contre eux non il ya une partie de la
population ce n'est pas tout le monde
nous avons appris à nous battre et à
gagner et nous avons fait ça depuis le
premier jour et vous disiez que vous
avez ressenti un sentiment de joie en
arrivant dans centre ville ce matin tout
à fait la joie des irakiens qui étaient
là qui célébrait et on était tout
simplement heureux de leur avoir donné
l'occasion d'exprimer cette joie en
parlant avec certaines personnes
aujourd'hui ils n'ont pas vraiment eu
l'occasion de faire cela dans toute leur
vie de cette finale librement et de me
dire quels sont les autres ni eau ni de
s'exprimer contre le régime contre la
vérité du régime c'est une un très beau
sentiment et avec un peu de chance ça va
se finir vie les irakiens pourront
établir instaurer un gouvernement du pr
mans élus oui parce que tout de même
dernière chose capitaine men gamme vous
avez conscience que pour une partie est
peut-être une grande partie de la
population vous êtes une force
d'occupation à bagdad
je ne sais pas qui vous a dit fin nous
avons été accueillis très bien il y a
très certainement des personnes qui ont
peur de dire que nous avons été bien
accueillis alors que le régime était
encore en place je n'ai pas eu le
sentiment de la part de ces gens qu'on
était une force d'occupation n'a été
bien accueilli et je crois que les gens
se rendent compte que la puritaine et
l'école c'est que une fois que les
irakiens pourront gouverner pour eux
mêmes quand ils pourront établir un
gouvernement les comment
démocratiquement élu comme aux états
unis en france
alors tout ça sera fini nous allons
faciliter ce changement de régime
c'est notre objectif mais je ne pense
pas que nous soyons des occupants pas du
tout je crois que les gens nous voient
comme des libérateurs et je crois que
c'est plus exact merci capitaine mme
ngân de nous avoir accordé ces quelques
minutes et on reste avec les militaires
américains depuis trois semaines
maintenant vous l'avez peut être
constaté nos reporters agnès vahramian
et patrick début il y suivre une unité
de marines c'est avec eux qu'ils sont
entrés en début d'après midi dans le
centre de la ville voici le reportage
les marines au coeur de bagdad
quelques tirs et leur riposte le 7e
régiment de combat prend position tout
autour de ce jardin écarte aussi les
voitures qui se dirigent vers les
soldats nous sommes au pied de
l'esplanade des martyrs de la guerre
iran irak
le monument est vide pas un seul ennemi
en vue
la plupart d'entre eux n'ont pas l'air
de vouloir se battre ils veulent juste
que saddam parts comme nous le voulons
il se met à côté nous laisse faire notre
travail
en face l'académique police détruites
au milieu la mosquée intacte aux
alentours des tireurs embusqués déloger
à la mitrailleuse lourde
je pense qu'ils se sont repliés vers la
ville ils ont vu du monde
il voulait tirer des coups de feu en
fait il voulait savoir jusqu'où ils
pouvaient aller dans l'après-midi les
marines se sont passées très vite devant
les blindés à l'abandon de l'armée
irakienne 10 km les dix derniers franchi
les yeux fermés sur les pillages sans
encombre sans résistance je ne sais pas
ici il y avait beaucoup de soldats
irakiens
hier beaucoup d'avions sont venus ils
ont lancé des roquettes
et qu'est ce que vous ressentez
je ne sais pas ce que je ressens tu
n'arrive pas à l'exprimer
mission accomplie en fin de journée
seuls quelques bâtiments brûlés autour
de nous l'ordre a été simultanée 3
régiment de marines sont entrés en même
temps dans bagdad
cet après-midi le 7e régiment de combat
la lima compagnie que le suivons depuis
quinze jours devrait parcourir encore
quelques kilomètres avant de faire la
jonction avec le us army venus par le
côté ouest est à noter qu'un délégué
canadien de la croix rouge a été tué
dans un échange de tirs aujourd'hui et
puis on est toujours sans nouvelles du
cameraman français de la chaîne
britannique haïti m frédéric nérac
une page est donc tournée en irak on
évoquera le cas de saddam hussein dans
un instant mais les dignitaires du
régime les ministres et les autres ont
eu eux aussi disparu
ceux là mêmes qui il ya quelques jours
encore tenait le pays d'une main de fer
richard miné
c'était la dernière parole officiel du
régime irakien hier vers midi le
ministre de l'information mohamed saïd
al sarraf apparaissait dans bagdad pour
assurer qu'aucun américain n'avait pu
pénétrer dans la capitale depuis aucun
dignitaire du régime n'est réapparue
invisible tarek aziz le vice premier
ministre irakien bras droit de saddam
hussein ici lors d'une ultime interview
à une télévision occidentales le 31 mars
dernier
envolée aussi houssard yehuda y ait deux
fils du dictateur
seul l'ambassadeur irakien aux nations
unies à new york est encore visible il
semble avoir perdu tout contact avec sa
hiérarchie
je ne sais rien c'est la guerre il y
aura un gagnant et un perdant
c'est la situation je n'ai pas d'autres
informations vous avez des contacts
depuis longtemps piste privilégiée un
repli des survivants du régime vers
tikrit la ville natale du président le
berceau de son pouvoir
peut-être la seule ville où les
manifestations de ce genre juste avant
la guerre ne sont pas factice
les américains ne s'y sont pas trompés
ces derniers jours ils ont intensifié
leurs bombardements sur la cité du nord
de l'irak
autre piste plus improbables un exil par
exemple vers la syrie là où est né le
parti baas
personne ne semble aujourd'hui savoir où
s'est réfugié le régime déchu
seul au liban nabih berri président du
parlement aux une information saddam
hussein aurait trouvé refuge à
l'ambassade de russie à bagdad
seule certitude ils étaient tous autour
de saddam hussein avant-hier pour une
réunion au sommet c'est peut-être la
corée et élaborer un plan de fuite qui
apparemment aurait réussi
oui richard been a évoqué la syrie c'est
semble-t-il la piste privilégiée par
washington donald rumsfeld indique que
des hauts responsables irakiens s'enfuit
en ce moment vers ce pays frontalier de
l'irak
saddam hussein on en parlait ses statuts
on l'a vu sont abattues ces portraits
eux sont enlevés ou saccagés images ici
d'un curieux tableau près de kerbala
le vrai saddam lui donc a disparu est il
mort sous les décombres du restaurant
bombardé il ya deux jours les américains
procéderont peut-être à des analyses adn
pour le vérifier
en tout cas c'est la fin d'un règne 34
ans d'un régime de terreur chiffre à 10
quand saddam hussein le lay qui n'a
jamais été militaires allaient prier à
la mosquée en uniforme
il enlevait son revolver la caméra
officiels se faisaient pas leur public
mais trop tard
l'uniforme c'est celui de son parti de
base qu'il organisait comme une armée
pour en faire le socle de sa dictature
une dictature dont la cruauté expéditive
n'épargner personne en juillet 1979 le
lendemain de son accession à la
présidence
il dénonce un complot à l'intérieur même
du parti baas et tandis qu'on fait
d'appel des coupables désignés
beaucoup seront fusillés saddam hussein
à la tribune fume un cigare
dès cette époque l'occident europe comme
états unis connaît la vraie nature du
régime irakien mais ne veut voir que
saddam hussein le réformiste saddam de
bâtisseur qui modernise son pays
et quand en septembre 1980 il déclare la
guerre à l'iran où les ayatollahs
viennent de prendre le pouvoir
l'occident qui s'inquiètent déjà de la
contagion islamique de soutien première
grave erreur de saddam hussein il
pensait que le nouveau régime des
ayatollahs des s'effondrer huit ans et
un million de morts plus tard la guerre
se termine sans vainqueur deuxième
erreur alors que la propagande
officielle nous livre des images d'un
président irakien qui s'adonnent en
famille et des plaisirs simples pour
mater la rébellion kurde
il fait gazer les 8000 habitants du
village d'halabja impossible pour les
occidentaux de cacher plus longtemps que
saddam hussein possède des armes de
destruction massive dont parfois il
acquis la technologie en occident
pourtant le dictateur irakien restent
très fréquentable et même très courtisé
il a du pétrole beaucoup l'irak
c'est la deuxième réserve mondiale tout
lui réussit encore et sa propagande le
fait savoir en août 1990 pour du pétrole
justement et pour un plus large accès à
la mer ils décident d'envahir le petit
koweit et de l'annexé troisième erreur
il vient de franchir une ligne rouge il
a sous-estimé des réactions
internationales contre saddam hussein
l'occident bâti la plus grande coalition
jamais réunie à l'époque sous la
direction de bush père alors président
des états unis
ce sera la première guerre du golfe de
janvier 91 sous mandat de l'onu cette
fois-là saddam hussein et des faits
trois semaines mais épargné lui et sa
dictature par les oxydants
la suite ce sera une répression féroce
contre les chiites du sud qui tente une
révolte
deux cent mille morts au moins et contre
les kurdes un régime de sanctions
imposées par l'onu plus de dix ans
d'embargo international dont la vraie
vie qui ne sera pas le dictateur mais le
peuple irakien quatrième erreur ne pas
avoir compris que bush fils était
déterminé à me faire une guerre que
l'irak ne pouvait pas gagner vendredi
dernier saddam hussein avait pris un
bain de foule dans une rue de bagdad
lundi des américains bombardaient cette
rue pensant détruire le bunker
souterrain où le président irakien se
serait réfugié ce soir la dictature est
mort saddam hussein et ils aussi
l'espoir des américains c'est que ce
dernier bain de foule ce dernier défi
soit aussi sa dernière erreur une
réaction la réaction d'un irakien à
cette journée à bagdad la vôtre monsieur
bascharage awad basharat vous êtes
éditeur
réalisateur producteur et vous êtes
installés en france
quel a été votre sentiment lorsque vous
avez découvert ces images aujourd'hui
c'était le grand soulagement
c'était une joie il les mettait immense
pour moi c'est la libération c'est la
renaissance pour moi c'est ccc une date
sera gravé dans ma tête jusqu'à la mort
je n'oublierai jamais cet instant vous
avez des mes proches à bagdad que vous
avez contacté ces dernières heures ou
des amis où j'ai énormément d'amis mais
mes proches sont à babylone j'ai pas
réussi malheureusement les contacter
mais j'ai quand même des nouvelles
rassurantes mais bon les gens là bas
sont très contents et moi j'ai partagé
lors leur joie vous avez envie d'y aller
vous même maintenant d'y retourner a
certainement g à d aller une fois c'est
dans vos projets ah oui ça c'est dans le
dos les médias dès les jours qui
viennent je vous prépare pour partir
monsieur bachar on l'a aussi entendu
quand même dans les reportages et puis
certaines remarques des américains à
bagdad la grande capitale du monde arabe
est-ce que ça provoque peut provoquer
aussi une réaction de rejet on a entendu
aussi dans notre partage c'est pas une
réaction de rejet à certaines éléments
qui n'acceptaient pas ça moi même aussi
gilles n'a pas accepté facilement la
présence américaine dans la ville de
bagdad est même meilleur parce que c'est
synonyme de d'occupation de colonialisme
c'est sartre sentiments partagés mais en
moins pour le moment il faut savourer le
moment deux victoires de renversement de
saddam hussein et la fin de régime qui a
écrasé le peuple et le pays
après on verra comment tu peux gérer
l'après saddam il relations avec les
états unis la chute de saddam hussein
c'est l'essentiel pour vous exactement
c'est la priorité absolue alors regardez
monsieur basharat comment réagissent
d'autres irakiens qui habite en france
c'est pauline revenant à et christophe
vignal qui étaient à leurs côtés
aujourd'hui
on donne l'histoire ce moment là ils ne
sont pas prêts de l'oublier
la statue de saddam hussein vacille et
sous leurs yeux le régime s'effondre
adil tient ce restaurant de sarcelles
depuis 11 ans il est né à bagdad
sa soeur et sa belle famille vivent
encore là bas ils sont deux à bagdad
on n'a pas réussi à le rejoindre depuis
le bombardement au delà deux centrales
de la télécommunication bombardée depuis
trois semaines
la capitale est tombé rapidement sous la
poussée des gi's ya pas parce que non à
marle pop et on en a marre de cette
situation depuis longtemps il a souffert
beaucoup parce que c'est la troisième ce
qui s'était vraiment ces régions elle se
fait beaucoup plaisir j'en ai vraiment
dense et applaudir 500 moore soulagement
mais aussi inquiétude face à l'avenir
encore incertain là bas
ensemble ils ont la liberté de parler ça
c'est important quand même ça commence
un peu mais j'espère qu'il y aura pas de
la guerre civile après la page saddam
hussein se tourne mais les discussions
continuent
comment reconstruire comment faire pour
oublier la dictature il faut changer les
lois il faut changer l'origine il faut
changer le régime parlementaire
il faut changer beaucoup de choses pour
avoir la démocratie et ça prend beaucoup
de temps on peut lancer un jour
peut-être pourquoi
et on retourne en irak avec une autre
réaction attendue celle du sud du pays
dont la plupart des villes sont
maintenant contrôlé vous ne savez par la
coalition c'est le cas par exemple de
bassorah alors il ya certes du
soulagement mais encore une fois la
première préoccupation est ailleurs
comment trouver à boire et à manger
envoyés spéciaux à bassorah
christian hottin océan grenier l'os est
devenue l'obsession quotidienne des
habitants de passera surtout par cette
canicule plus de 40 degrés à l'ombre
aujourd'hui cette fontaine improvisé
sorti du sol est une aubaine et quand on
a soif on n'est pas trop regardant sur
la qualité de ce que l'on voit ses taux
elle n'est pas potable
elle donne mal au ventre dans ce
contexte de pénurie l'événement du jour
la chute de bagdad est passée presque
inaperçue même si cela réjouit
quelques-uns je suis très heureux que
bagdad soit tombé je veux dire merci à
monsieur boucher à monsieur blair nous
sommes libres maintenant d'autres ne
sont pas au courant
nous n'avons pas de nouvelles de bagdad
juste à la télévision apparemment la
télévision de ce monsieur n'en a pas
parlé
il faut dire qu'ici à bassorah en ce
moment on al'esprit ailleurs trop occupé
à piller à récupérer tout ce qui peut
l'être pour leur apporter par n'importe
quel moyen
cet après midi les trois grands que du
centre-ville ont été la proie des
pilleurs mais il n'y avait rien dans les
coffres et voleurs ont alors essayé de
faire sauter la chambre forte
c'est là que les troupes britanniques
sont intervenus pour repousser les
assaillants
et c'est l'une des premières fois que
les anglais s'opposent à ceux qui
pillent la ville depuis trois jours
nous pouvons gérer ces gens nous avons
les équipements pour cela nos gars sont
très bien entraînés pour ce genre de
choses
s'ils l'ont déjà fait en irlande du nord
pendant des années c'est juste qu'on
pensait pas devoir le faire ici mais en
l'absence de pouvoir civil les
militaires britanniques auront bien du
mal à faire régner lors le président
bush a promis la liberté de quoi vivre
au peuple irakien mais deux jours après
la prise de la ville de bassorah par les
anglais la ville est livrée aux pillards
est la population irakienne attend
toujours l'aide humanitaire capable de
la soulager
et précisément les américains ont
l'intention d'installer un pont aérien
daide humanitaire
les premiers avions d'après washington
serait déjà arrivé à l'aéroport de
bagdad
toujours dans le sud à oum cassard
images du principal camp de prisonniers
irakiens
quelques 5000 personnes sur un total de
7000 selon la coalition
et puisqu'on en est aux premiers bilans
parlons des morts les chiffres sont très
floues côté irakien entre 500 et 900
personnes selon des estimations données
avant-hier par les autorités elles mêmes
avant leur fuite il s'agirait des seuls
civils
mais le chiffre est évidemment sujet à
caution côté britannique
trente soldats seraient morts et 96 côté
américain et c'est évidemment un élément
important pour washington bonsoir
thierry thuiller politiquement rien
n'est joué mais ce soir après trois
semaines de guerre on peut dire que
militairement les américains ont tenu
leurs objectifs
oui souvenez-vous david avant le début
des opérations donald rumsfeld avait
prédit que la guerre durerait six jours
ou bien six semaines
en tout cas pas des mois il vient cela
aura duré finalement trois semaines
trois semaines pour faire chuter le
régime de saddam hussein après un
flottement au début des opérations dans
le sud du pays du fait de la résistance
irakienne bien la machine militaire
américaine s'est mise en marche et c'est
finalement avec très peu de soldats
quelques milliers seulement que bagdad
est tombée aujourd'hui donc pour le
moment la stratégie de donald rumsfeld
est un succès d'autant que vous l'avez
dit le bilan des pertes américaines est
très faible mais il faut dire aussi que
le déséquilibre des forces était bien
trop grand et l'armée irakiennes la
garde républicaine ne se sont pas
battues ou très peu et c'est vrai qu'on
se demande ce soir où est passée l'armée
irakienne et comme d'habitude j'allais
dire bien ce sont finalement les civils
qui ont payé les civils irakiens qui ont
payé le plus
tribut à cette guerre ce sera très
certainement un élément à prendre en
compte par les américains pour l'après
guerre pour l'irak sans saddam hussein
merci thierry vous restez avec nous
cette guerre qui n'est pas terminé 1
rappelons le il y à la ville de tikrit
ton en parlait il ya aussi les villes
très importante de mossoul et de kirkouk
plus au nord mossoul où les américains
alliés aux combattants kurdes ont
réalisé une nouvelle percée aujourd'hui
envoyés spéciaux jérôme baugnies olivier
robert quand les pechmergas font du
tourisme
quand il découvre la beauté du monastère
saint mathieu à ma club dont le régime
de saddam hussein les a trop longtemps
privée c'est ici que ça mathieu a fini
sa vie dans la perse du 4e siècle et ce
qui intéresse surtout les combattants
kurdes
c'est la situation du monastère à flanc
de montagne surplombant la ville de
mossoul et ses champs pétrolifères des
frappes américaines que le moma trouve a
pu être investi par les flèches merga
qui ont vaincu sans péril les irakiens
n'ont pas supporté la violence des
bombardements nous explique cet officier
beaucoup de soldats sont morts les
autres et battu en retraite
la route qui mène à ma klum est jonchée
d'épaves la caserne a été abandonnée les
soldats irakiens qui ont laissé toutes
sortes de munitions roquettes anti chars
aux obus de mortier bien inutile contre
les avions les pechmergas nous montrent
leur but sans précaution particulière
jour après jour les combattants
progresse
grâce à l'appui de l'aviation américaine
mais ici nous sommes à 30 km de mossoul
que les kurdes revendiquent là-bas la
population et du kurde affirme se pêche
maire gaston parle kurdes on y est utile
aux kurdes mossoul et kirkouk font
partie le calice temps pour les
américains aujourd'hui la priorité est
de calmer l'ardeur de ces kurdes que la
turquie surveille de très près jérôme
monier on vous retrouve en direct à
erbil pas très loin de là bonsoir jérôme
quelles conséquences peut avoir cette
chute du régime irakien sur ce front du
nord
est ce qu'on espère par exemple une
rébellion à mossoul et kirkouk
écoutez c'est un fait que danser ville
de mossoul et de kirkouk semble-t-il il
y à un certain nombre de kurdes malgré
l'arabisation de ces régions alors
évidemment le moindre signe de faiblesse
du régime va encourager ces populations
à se révolter alors ici on assiste à une
accélération du processus des opérations
militaires on voit que les bases
américaines sont consolidées et le but
bien sûr c'est d'aller vers ces champs
pétrolifères pourquoi pas seulement pour
faire échec à ce qui resterait d'une
résistance irakienne mais aussi pour
contrôler les puits de pétrole parce que
bien sûr vous savez que ces puits de
pétrole sont convoqués par les kurdes
qui ce soir vous l'entendez sont très
heureux de ce qu'est en train de se
passer à bagdad donc ces kurdes voit la
chute du régime
et ils ont toujours considéré comme
mossoul et kirkouk comme le disait dans
le sujet faisait partie du kurdistan
mais les turcs bien sûr sont très
inquiet les turcs ne veulent pas d'un
kurdistan consolidé par l'assise
économique énorme que représente bien
sûr ses champs pétrolifères alors la
mission essentielle des américains c'est
sans doute dans la région surtout de
sécuriser ces puits de pétrole et
d'éviter une espèce de ruée vers l'or
noir qui ne pourrait qu inquiéter l
allié turc
merci jérôme en tout cas au kurdistan
des scènes de joie ont effectivement
suivi la nouvelle de la chute de bagdad
reportage vincent nguyen hubert martin
oui ce sont bien des kalachnikovs qui
claquent les elle ne vise que le ciel un
gros nuage vient de mourir et le soleil
brille sur le drapeau kurde
bagdad est en train de tomber la guerre
n'est pas finie tant pis les habitants
der wiel c'est déjà la libération du
régime de saddam hussein
les kurdes ont que trop souffert c'est
le plus beau jour de notre vie crie les
gamins on était part à cette saddam en
anglais le répertoire de fucking saddam
à bouche iloveyou
le président américain et son allié
britannique sont sans aucun doute les
héros du jour
ces kurdes ne savent pas ce que l'avenir
nous réserve mais demain est un autre
jour
pour l'instant on m'a dit que son t1
meilleur goût m'appelait ce 10e
anniversaire
on ignore si saddam est mort et son
régime est en lambeaux et les kurdes
sont sûrs que de l'ogre ne feront qu'une
bouchée
cette certitude évidemment ils écrivent
en américains et alors que les combats
continuent cette débâcle du régime ouvre
aussi bien sur le chapitre de la presse
adam hussein quelle place pour
l'opposition iranienne en exil qui
revient qui est déjà revenu mais qui est
très divisée bonsoir faysal chalabi vous
êtes le porte parole du congrès national
irakien le cni mouvement qui a disons la
faveur de washington et vous êtes aussi
le neveu de son dirigeant ahmad chalabi
vous êtes à koweït city
mais avant de vous entendre on va voir
pour la première fois à l'oeuvre ce
qu'on appelle les forces irakiennes
libre 700 hommes déjà en place dans le
sud de l'irak
ils ressemblent aux américains ils ont
l'uniforme des américains mais ce sont
bien les irakiens reportage de nos
envoyés spéciaux à nadjaf laurent
boussier dominique marault tel sabine
albertelli abbas adam abbas adam ce sont
des soldats irakiens ce sont les héros
de la liberté joie véritable ou signe de
soumission nouveau pouvoir qui se met en
place c'était ce matin l'accueil de la
population de nadja à la première entrée
dans une ville irakienne de soldats
issus de la résistance à saddam hussein
une première parade avec un succès
assuré puis très vite dans l'après midi
la mise en place d'un système de
sécurité
nous allons établir ici la première
nouvelle force de police en irak qui va
s'occuper des affaires civiles car les
pillages continuent cette police
veillera à ce que toutes les religions
soit tolérée est à ce que l'irak
devienne une démocratie où les gens
auront une vie meilleure
c'est dans les locaux de la police que
le colonel abdul monem lui même ancien
policier va installer son quartier
général entouré et conseillé par les
hommes des forces spéciales américaines
il a donc pour mission de rétablir
l'ordre dans la ville puis dans la
région déjà les premières arrestations
ont eu lieu pour eux les ennuis
commencent pour d'autres au contraire
c'est une sorte de revanche après avoir
passé deux ans dans cette prison raïs
abdallahi a rejoint la résistance
originaire de nadjaf il a tenu à nous
faire visiter les cellules dans
lesquelles il a été détenu et torturé ce
mal français c'est lui ils ont fermé les
prisonniers juste avant de les pendre
ici c'était pour les maisons qui
s'opposer au régime
une cellule sans lumière à part celle
des soupirails là il nous pendait par
les poignets pendant des heures c'était
ça les méthodes de saddam hussein alors
parler de liberté
avant de partir les hommes de saddam
hussein ont essayé de détruire le
maximum de preuves mais çà et là en
trouve encore des listes de personnes
arrêtées leur empreinte leur photo et
les registres de la prison
à l'extérieur le douce a succédé à la
liesse dans cette ville catalogué pro
saddam il y a quelques semaines encore
sur les visages se lit presque
l'inquiétude beaucoup se posent des
questions sur les nouveaux arrivants sur
les nouveaux maîtres de la ville
les américains font donc faire le
travail de nettoyage et de sécurisation
de la ville aux irakiens une manière
pour eux de ne pas apparaître dans la
ville une manière pour eux de rester à
l'extérieur des problèmes voilà on va
retrouver faysal chalabi dans un instant
nous avons un petit souci du côté de
koweït city donc en attendant les
réactions à cette chute de bagdad
qu'en dit on dans les villes arabes que
dit-on de la présence des chars
américains dans la capitale historique
du monde arabe à amman en jordanie
reportage florence bouki à frédéric
faure la stupeur dans la capitale
jordanienne
depuis 21 jours minute par minute la rue
se tient informé de la situation en irak
à bagdad
la statue de saddam hussein vient de
tomber les frères irakiens auraient donc
baisser les armes
les jordaniens ne peuvent y croire
baghdad n'est pas tombé c'est ça qu'il
faut comprendre bagdad c'est la capitale
des arabes
ces irakiens qui crient leur joie de ce
sont des pantins les américains les ont
ramenés de toutes les régions ce sont
les gens de l'opposition des pros
américains à des 13 c'est ce trottoir
mêler aux jordaniens quelques irakiens
réfugiés à man certains ne sont venus
ici que pour trouver du travail
d'autres ont fui le régime de saddam le
ton monte on va refaire la même
révolution qu'au siècle dernier
et inchallah notre régime
reviendra-t-elle qu'il était si rien ne
m'empêche si dieu veut je vais revoir ma
famille mort ou vivant je rentre à
bagdad
la discussion du roi longtemps mais tous
jordanien palestiniens irakiens de tous
bords sont d'accord sur une chose les
américains doivent quitter l'irak
très vite cet après-midi le ministre
jordanien des affaires étrangères a
déclaré solennellement que le peuple
irakien doit dorénavant décider sol de
son futur un message peut être d'abord
destiné à la rue jordanienne car depuis
le début de la guerre le pouvoir ici
affirme son soutien aux américains alors
que le peuple lui
supporte pas l'idée d'une occupation par
les américains d'un pays arabes voisins
et frères alors précisément quels
scénarios pour l'après guerre c'est bien
sûr l'une des questions ce soir nous
retrouverons donc faysal chalabi merci
d'être avec nous c'est bien vous cette
fois en chair et en os on vous voit vous
êtes je le disais le porte parole du
congrès national irakien
l'un des principaux mouvements
d'opposition et qui a les faveurs des
états unis d'abord un mot sur une
déclaration de votre oncle qui dirige le
cni et qui disait il ya quelques heures
d'après moi saddam hussein est en fuite
mais il est toujours vivant est ce que
vous avez des précisions qu'est ce qui
justifie cette déclaration je n'ai pas
plus de précisions sur le sort de saddam
hussein mais je pense qu'il est de plus
en plus importants et
de plus en plus
ému
son emprise psychologique sur le papier
raquin existe de moins en moins ça
n'existe pas un rêve à peu près certain
monsieur chalabi les autres mouvements
d'opposition irakien refusent eux de
s'investir dans l'après guerre
si l'administration américaine supervise
cette après guerre il souhaiterait que
l'onu s'en occupe
pourquoi préférez-vous washington aux
nations unies enfin nous préférons
washington tout simplement parce que
nous pensons que nous avons besoin d'un
appui très puissant pour entreprendre
toutes les réformes nécessaires de
l'état irakien si bien il ya un
programme de débassification qui est
nécessaire le parti baas est présent sur
tous les échelons de l'état irakien et
ces instances doivent être pratiquement
1 ces petits êtres même exemple au même
titre que l'allemagne de l'après-guerre
a été des nazis fier et que le japon a
dû être démilitarisé mais ne craignez
vous pas une réaction hostile de la
population irakienne a une présence
prolongée des américains nous pensons
que les américains vont très bien savoir
nous appuyer et vont guider les irakiens
dans cette entreprise
d'où leur présence à l'isie leurs prêts
leur présence sur place va être un
sérieux appui au peuple irakien et vont
essais américains les forces de la
coalition vont nous fournir les outils
et la plateforme nécessaires à cette
démocratisation de l'irak
monsieur chalabi que les gens
malheureusement la bureaucratie que
malheureusement la bureaucratie devenu
ne pourra pas faire monsieur chalabi
j'imagine que votre oncle est candidat à
plus ou moins long terme aux plus hautes
responsabilités en irak mais s'il est
contesté
il est vrai je le disais que
l'opposition est divisée mais on lui
reproche notamment d'avoir quitté l'irak
à l'âge de 11 ans et de ne plus
connaître le pays ces choses là sont
assez futile parce qu'il s'agit de
considérer en fait que tous les que tous
les irakiens qui sont en exil ils sont
plus de 4 millions sont des citoyens de
seconde zone
c'est c
le changement devait venir de
l'extérieur viendra de l'extérieur et se
mélangera au peuple et
et voilà toutes les expériences sont
utiles dans la reconstruction dira quel
choix de l'intérieur ou de l'extérieur
il n'y a pas de différenciation entre
les gens qui étaient en exil les
irakiens qui étaient en exil et les gens
des irakiens qui étaient restés à
l'intérieur
merci fait seule celle à bien vous étiez
en direct de koweït city merci d'avoir
été avec nous et direction les états
unis maintenant d'un point de vue
américain cette chute de bagdad ne
justifie pas la guerre certes mais
conforte ses partisans à new york nous
retrouvons l'un de nos correspondants
pascal golomer il y a trois semaines
exactement c'est ici à times square que
des centaines d'américains avaient
appris sur écran géant le début de la
guerre aujourd'hui sous une pluie
glaciale
ils étaient bien peu à s'arrêter pour
suivre en direct la chute de bagdad il
faut dire qu'avant de partir au travail
beaucoup avaient déjà suivi dans la
matinée les émissions spéciales
proposées par toutes les grandes chaînes
de télévision les images de bagdad en
liesse sont diffusées en continu mais le
ton des commentaires à l'antenne se veut
encore prudent
une prudence qu'on retrouve dans les
rues de manhattan
même si on ne découvre pas d'armes de
destruction massive ce sera une bonne
chose d'être venu à bout de cet empire
du mal si cruel qui pratiquaient la
torture et le viol il ya peut-être
encore des forces irrégulières qui
traînent ils disent que le régime est
tombé mais je ne sais pas si on peut
vraiment croire
il y en a encore pour un moment avant
que notre eau proviennent s'il en est un
en revanche qui devant de telles images
a du mal à contenir sa satisfaction
c'est bien le vice président dick cheney
favorable depuis longtemps à une telle
intervention au tout début des
opérations militaires
notre plan a été critiqué par des
généraux à la retraite
incorporé dans les studios de télévision
et le déroulement des combats au
frigidaire clairement démontré la
sagesse de ce plan la bourse elle n'a
pas sauté au plafond loin de là bien sûr
dans les salles de marché on jette un
oeil sur les écrans de télévision
mais on songe surtout aux difficultés à
venir pas de hausse spectaculaire des
indices donc personne ne s'est
précipités pour acheter des actions
ça reste une indication qu'il ya
prudence les marchés bougent parce que
bas ont réagi aux news ont réagi à la
télévision réagi aux images mais dans
des volumes relativement faibles qui
prouve que les vrais les vrais
intervenantes sont pas là pas de fort et
uni d'optimisme excessif ici à new york
les américains savent bien que même si
la bataille de bagdad semble terminée il
est encore trop tôt pour crier victoire
bonsoir etienne leenhardt washington la
modestie est donc de mise visiblement
oui si jubilation il y à david elle est
restée en coulisse bien bien caché il
est bientôt trois heures de l'après-midi
et george bush n'a pas sorti la tête de
la maison blanche de la journée son
porte-parole a simplement dit qu'il
était heureux pour les irakiens qu'il
avait regardé les événements de ce matin
à la télévision
entre deux réunions que lorsque la
statue de saddam hussein s'était
effondré dans le centre de bagdad il
s'était exclamée la statue est tombé
crillon modeste donc et c'est sans doute
calculé dans la mesure où on l'a dit
répété
et bien ce qui attend les américains
maintenant avec la reconstruction de
l'irak risque d'être une tâche au moins
aussi complexe que la guerre elle-même
oui triomphe modeste etienne mais déjà
on brandit cette victoire comme un
avertissement
oui il ya des déclarations qui sont
effectivement assez inquiétante celle de
l'un des adjoints de monsieur colline
powell qui s'appelle john bolton qui est
sous secrétaire d'état donc au ministère
des affaires étrangères qui est réputé
pour être un conservateur et qui a dit
ce matin à l'adresse de la syrie donc
des syriens à damas et bien que la syrie
serait ferait bien de méditer l'exemple
irakien sous entendu si vous participez
ou si vous soutenez des actes
terroristes il vous arrivera la même
chose monsieur roussel vient de redire
également vient de lancer un nouvel
avertissement à la syrie il ya une
demi-heure à peine au pentagone
il me semble qu'il s'agit plus de
menaces rhétorique qu'autre chose la
plupart des observateurs ici sont
persuadés au contraire que les états
unis vont maintenant se concentrer sur
la reconstruction de l'irak mais aussi
de l'afghanistan où ils sont présents
depuis un an et demi un pays qui n'est
toujours pas sécurisée et puis également
que dans les prochains mois monsieur
bush va s'occuper de l'économie
américaine qui vous le savez ne va pas
bien pour ne pas rééditer les erreurs de
son père qui avait gagné une guerre en
1991 et qui dans la foulée un an après
avait perdu les élections parce que le
portefeuille des américains n'allait pas
bien et qu'un jeune gouverneur de
l'arkansas qui s'appelait bill clinton
le leur avait dit le leur avait fait
comprendre qu'il avait fini par
remporter l'élection
merci etienne réaction aussi de
tony blair le sourire de tony blair
c'est et aux communes tout à leur
premier ministre britannique s'est dit
enchanté de cette information
concernant la chute du régime de saddam
hussein et puis les réactions en france
où à quelques exceptions près vous le
savez la classe politique était d'accord
avec jacques chirac et dominique de
villepin pour refuser cette guerre alors
la chute de bagdad
fait-elle chanceler les positions
réponse avec alexandre kara dans les
couloirs de l'assemblée après trois
semaines de silence prudent à
l'assemblée nationale on s'exprime de
nouveau sur l'irak
si les ténors des parties évitent les
micros la plupart des députés eux
n'hésitent pas à parler je suis heureux
de la victoire des américains car
jusqu'à nouvel ordre
le cran de la liberté plutôt de l'autre
côté de l'atlantique que le régime de
saddam hussein d'autres regrettent les
ambiguïtés passé c'est que mon pays la
france est par moment donné le sentiment
de choisir plus d'oublier l'époque leur
aspiration à la liberté pour dire oui la
paix mais pour laisser les dictateurs
under pour certains c'est même un
véritable fiasco diplomatique
l'accueil par les populations libérés de
leurs libérateurs est exactement celle
que l'on pouvait attendre
or malheureusement notre diplomatie a
dit le contraire malheureusement nous
avons changé nos alliances et
aujourd'hui il est peut-être un temps de
reconnaître nos erreurs
ce n'est pas l'analyse des députés qui
ont toujours critiqué l'intervention de
la coalition
je crois qu'aujourd'hui au moment où on
discute de paix le rôle qu'a joué le
président de la république
l'écho qu'il a acquis dans les pays du
moyen-orient renforcée suite à cette
crise à mon avis rend la position
française plus crédible enfin côté
socialiste si on ne regrette pas le
régime
c'est surtout sur le futur qu'on associe
personne ne va verser une larme et en
tout cas ce ne sera pas mon cas sur
saddam hussein et son régime cc c'est un
régime atroce moss et dénoncent depuis
très longtemps
le problème maintenant c'est de savoir
si on va collectivement gagner la paix
et si on ne dit pas devant la caméra
pour beaucoup député la conclusion est
la même
diplomatiquement pour la france le plus
dur reste à venir
thierry thulliez 7 le déroulement des
opérations militaires ne risque pas de
mettre les positions françaises un peu
en porte à faux
il c'est vrai que le scénario de la
guerre peut la mettre en porte à faux
il donne en tout cas de l'eau au moulin
à ceux qui à washington pense qu'anthony
est loué nu dans un rôle marginal et
d'ailleurs on voit bien que les
américains veulent accélérer le
mouvement ils ont annoncé la réunion une
réunion de l'opposition dans les
prochains jours à bagdad pour mettre en
place une administration provisoire est
pour le moment dans leur tête il n'est
absolument pas question de l'eau et
merci thierry voilà ce que nous pouvions
dire sur cette journée capitale bien sûr
dans cette guerre de l'irak
le reste de l'actualité en bref ce sont
d'abord ces quatre palestiniens tués à
beit hanoun dans la bande de gaza après
une nouvelle incursion de l'armée
isrélienne incursions menées au
lendemain d'une opération de liquidation
contre un responsable de la branche
militaire du hamas
qui avait été tué avec six autres
palestiniens toujours à gaza
sachez par ailleurs qu'une grenade a
explosé dans une école près de jénine en
cisjordanie
29 blessés dont quatre graves attentats
revendiqués par un groupe juif d'extrême
droite
on reparle de ben laden avec un nouvel
enregistrement l' agence de presse
américaine qui lui attribuent ce message
audio que vous entendez dans lequel le
chef d'al qaïda appelle les musulmans à
organiser des attentats suicide a
attaqué les pays arabes qui soutiennent
la coalition il était muet depuis le
début de la guerre en irak
enregistrement impossible bien sûr à
authentifier en france on retiendra ce
projet de loi sur la criminalité
organisée
présenté aujourd'hui en conseil des
ministres deux mesures principales un
statut de repenti d'abord avec des
réductions de peines prévues pour ceux
qui dénoncent pont des complices
et puis la possibilité de plaider
coupable comme dans certains pays anglo
saxons l'accusé qui reconnaît les faits
pour être ainsi éviter une instruction
et raccourcir les détentions provisoires
un rapport sur le divorce également
remis au garde des sceaux
objectif de cette réforme simplifier les
procédures
raccourcir les délais de baisser les
frais de justice limiter la portée du
divorce pour faute
un projet de loi devrait être présenté
en conseil des ministres au mois de mai
et une image de sport enfin avec le car
les quarts de finale aller de la ligue
des champions deux matières
le real madrid lors d'une rencontre
somptueuse à 28 ans manchester united 3
1 but signé figo écrit un doublé de raul
côté espagnol
côté anglais abuse de van nistelrooy
l'ajax et le milan ac ont fait match nul
0-0 suite des matchs ce soir
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci de l'avoir suivi tout de suite la
météo patrice drevet dans quelques
instants à téléfilm inédit et qui a déjà
reçu plusieurs prix une preuve d'amour
l'info sur france 2 dernier journal 1h20
jean claude renault demain dès 6h30
télématin dans les 4 vérités gérard
leclerc recevra frédéric joly porte
parole de la croix rouge
il sera bien sûr question de la
situation humanitaire en irak et on se
quitte précisément avec l'image symbole
de cette journée à bagdad la plus grande
des statuts
dan hussein déboulonnée en fin
d'après-midi à demain
ces cas